Speaker 1: Sarah Palin was asked to explain
why Trumpism is not a cult, and she explained
why Trumpism is a cult.
This is a really, really stunning video and
it confirms just about everything we've been
talking about for years now.
Sarah Palin appeared on Newsmax and she was
basically given one of these softball questions
where it's like Trump, people aren't cultists.
Right?
And Sarah Palin goes, Absolutely not, because
cultists are.
And then she defines it.
And she is, of course, describing Trumpists.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: I was with the Trump motorcade
yesterday, and I would say that the people
at Versace, at the Cuban restaurant, I wouldn't
call them cult members, would, you.
Speaker 3: Know, you know, the definition
of a cult is a group of people who are excessively
supporting one another and a cause all about
conformity and compliance and intolerance
of anyone who doesn't agree with what their
mission is.
Okay.
That's the definition of what the left is
engaged in right now.
Speaking of cults, all about conformity and
compliance and heaven forbid you don't agree
with them.
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best by just about
any accurate definition?
Hardcore MAGA is indeed a cult.
They have beliefs and practices that are strange
or even sinister, including denying the reality
of the world in so far as climate change,
COVID, the 2020 election results.
They worship Trump as this messianic figure
who can do no wrong must be obeyed at all
costs, and many of them even see him as a
pseudo deity.
They are characterized by their devotion not
only to Trump, but the ideology he espouses,
which they often express through symbols,
including MAGA hats or flags or banners or
signs and symbols.
They have a system of beliefs that are pseudo
religious and rituals which are directed towards
Trump.
They pray for him or they pray over him, as
we saw at the Cuban Cafe Vici in Miami on
Tuesday.
They attend his rallies and chant his slogans.
They stormed the Capitol on his behalf, committing
crimes on his behalf.
And they have this self-appointed leader,
Trump, who claims to be the only one that
can save them, that can save America.
And they believe it.
These are all cult traits.
And of course, Trump, for his part of it,
excessively controls his followers through
lies, fear, threats, manipulation, requiring
them to believe what he says and to do what
he wants.
Donating or voting or chanting or whatever
the case may be.
And these are all beliefs that most of the
world considers deviant or depraved and much
of the United States as well.
Compare this to Biden supporters.
Okay.
Biden supporters aren't obsessed with symbols
or rituals.
Biden supporters aren't obsessed with Biden.
In fact, most of us don't even really care
about Joe Biden.
Like what I mean by that is I don't want harm
to come to him, but I don't care about Biden
as a figure.
I'm not interested in defending Biden.
If he did something wrong, if he did something
wrong, investigate him or charge him or whatever.
I'm interested in policy and I'm interested
in ideas.
And if Biden is going to be the person to
push those, that's great.
And if it's somebody else, that's fine, too.
We don't consider Biden the ultimate source
of truth the way maggots consider Trump to
be.
I don't consider MSNBC or whatever Democratic
establishment media is out there to be the
ultimate source of truth, the way they consider,
whether it's Fox News or Newsmax or whatever,
is the flavor of the month to be an ultimate
source of truth.
I don't feel any need to reflexively defend
Biden against any criticism.
Yeah, Biden's just not progressive enough
on some policies.
Yeah, Biden's looking dramatically more frail
than he used to.
Yeah.
I also don't see criticisms of Biden as attacks
on the free world, on democracy, on the media,
on our country.
Okay.
Criticize Biden.
I'll tell you if I agree or if I disagree.
It is a dramatic contrast when you think about
what it means to be in a cult, a cult member,
a cult leader.
And Sarah Palin hilariously and trying to
say, no, no, no, no, there's no cult here,
actually confirmed There is indeed a cult